nombre d'élèves par classe respect des
gestes-barrières protection des
personnels l'équation a trop d'inconnues
pour le maire de chalon sur saône
il a décidé de ne pas rouvrir ces écoles
la semaine prochaine quand on discute
avec des directeurs d'école l'art
hiérarchie n'est pas en capacité
aujourd'hui de répondre quel type
d'enfant allons nous accueillir comment
voulez vous organisez une rentrée si
vous n'avez pas déjà le nombre et
surtout le nombre d'enfants qui seront
invitées prioritairement à l'école
sachant qu'on ne pourra pas tous les
accueillir
si nous n'avons pas fait ce travail
préalable moi je ne pourrais pas dire
famille votre enfant peut venir à
l'école en sécurité alors si je ne peux
pas dire qu'il vient l'école en sécurité
je ne rouvre pas l'école c'est aussi
simple que ça non loin de là dracy le
fort se prépare aussi
en attendant de connaître le nombre
d'élèves le maire essaye d'appliquer au
mieux le protocole sanitaire
alors ici c'est la classe des cm1-cm2
donc vous voyez aujourd'hui et les
configurer avec des petites tables
individuelles panneaux de signalisation
dans les toilettes ou encore des
barrières métalliques pour séparer les
enfants
en quelques semaines les directives et
recommandations se sont empilés sur le
bureau du maire nous avons le sentiment
que des décisions sont prises à paris
que ces décisions elles nous sont
imposées sur nos territoires
aujourd'hui moi je sens une certaine
solitude comme mère seule solution pour
avancer le dialogue permanent avec
l'équipe enseignante
nous avons pu échanger pour voir quels
étaient les pistes que les uns et les
autres nous nous avions en tête et
partager et c'était la mère des choses
c'était la concertation avec les
enseignants d'écoles de dracy-le-fort la
décision d'accueillir les élèves le 14
mai sera prise ce jeudi
en accord avec la directrice de
l'établissement